it sounds like you have a marketing
problem and i had the same conversation
with the libertarians uh when we had the
libertarian roundtable debate they have
all these amazing ideas but
nothing breaks through because none of
their candidates
are charismatic or nobody's listening to
them so i'm going to throw something
your way and by the way i agree with you
on that analysis okay well thank you so
much i am i am a
a country boy from the north of
vancouver island with a science phd and
i know how to write about it and talk
about it yeah well let's say you are
absolutely correct is it fair to say
that you're not a fan of the new green
deal is that fair to say yeah that's
fair okay so we'll go there is it fair
to say that you're not a fan of the
paris climate accords
is that fair to say okay i'm just
painting a picture for you
so but you know who is
okay and i'm just gonna go down some
names here and just throw them out there
and this will get to my point of the
question about the marketing problem we
all know greta thundberg you've turned
you know 16 year old girl whatever maybe
she's 18 now you got leonardo dicaprio
you got al gore you have um
pharrell robert redford
um mark ruffalo joaquin feel like sir
david attenborough elon musk you can
throw him in that category jaden smith
if you're familiar with him will smith's
son big advocate of the uh did i just go
there with you just say jaden
okay
the list of names jane fonda the point
is you have all these celebrities
on the other side of your argument
yes for the most except they know
nothing about sex okay but that's my
point yeah and then and this essentially
you just basically answered my question
they're doing great at marketing you
have them some of the most famous people
in the world saying
listen to us we know what we're talking
about and then you have dr patrick moore
for the most part not a household name
smart guy on the other side so who's on
your who can you recruit
you know much like hollywood or the
celebrities or the the green new deal
crew the aoc crew who can you cre
recruit to be your biggest advocate to
say oh it's not just me it's not this
smart canadian scientist that's saying
this it's x y z a b c bing bing bing
bing bing it's a kind of even the
playing field because it sounds like you
have the exact same problem the
libertarians have all these amazing
ideas but it's lost in the echo chamber
and nobody's listening is that a fair
point do you understand what i'm saying
here
yes i don't know about the libertarian
analogy but you're right the point is
they don't have a charismatic leader or
leader you're right you're right about
the celebrity
analogy
um
i i don't know how to parse society in
in a way to give a decent answer to that
except all i know is i've worked all my
life in the environmental field
i've seen how it has changed and gone
off on a course that it's gone off on
now
where it's taking advantage of the
situation of people being afraid that
they're killing their grandchildren
while they're driving their car
and there
there are really no celebrities on the
science side most of the people on on
the science side that think like i do
are scientists will you have someone
like bill nye out there he's i would say
a you know celebrity scientist household
name yeah success a lot of the gen z
grew up with that guy
bill nye
um but the point is i know you're
shaking your head you're kind of bill
nye he's a joke a green new deal he's a
joke yeah paris climbing
yes those aren't jokes the paris climate
deal is not a joke it's an international
treaty
and it's based on the idea that a one
degree more rise in global temperature
will be a a disaster crisis an emergency
which is so ridiculous if you look at
the history of the temperature of the
earth i mean we're actually at the tail
end of a 50 million year cooling period
at this point in the place to see an ice
age
and yet they're saying it's too hot i
mean it's that simple
but you uh what do you do about fads and
cults and but who can popular roots to
well we have to get your message out we
have an essentially what i'm asking we
have an organization which is recruiting
it's called a co2 coalition it's based
in arlington virginia greg wrightstone
is the executive director he is a very
smart geologist who's who understands
the ages of the earth and he also
understands politics very well we just
had a really good win in pennsylvania
where a judge overturned the
pennsylvania greenhouse gas initiative
which was going to cost billions of
dollars and just like with the recent
supreme court decision on the epa and
co2
this is basically making the point that
these administrations the deep state
basically does not have the right to
overrule congress and to go beyond what
congress has approved this there's a
trend in that direction now and that is
a good trend and we are helping with
that with information directly to the
people who are making the decisions
so the co2 coalition here clint el is
it's a funny name but it's initials for
an uh a global warming uh group in
europe mainly it is now got over a
thousand people
who are real scientists behind it and so
we are organizing but we are not
politicians we're we're just not born
and we're not movie stars
you know so it's it's not an easy road
to hoe but the truth surely will
eventually
come to the surface
especially if the climate doesn't warm
very much in the next while which it
hasn't been doing for the last while
so we don't really have any big trend of
warming going on as a matter of fact
western north america was colder this
spring and early summer than it has been
for a long time but those aren't the
messages we're hearing the media that
well they don't report cold they only
report hot
you know so that's the other problem
that is a societal problem and a
political problem is the vast majority
of the media is fake now and they're not
reporting the southern border they're
not reporting the climate news i see
politicians saying that bangladesh now
has the biggest flood in 100 years they
have floods every year a hundred people
have died this year in floods just a few
years ago 400 people died in floods and
they're saying it's the biggest in 100
years and these are canadian members of
parliament who are is it the fact that
the media is actually fake or they more
just have an agenda and they want to
stick to that agenda in order there's a
difference there no in order to stick to
their agenda they must lie
that's what they're doing and they're
they know they're doing it
they absolutely know they're twisting it
and turning and ignoring they have two
strategies one is to lie the other one
is to ignore so a combination of lying
and ignoring works really well at making
the population ignorant of what's really
going on in the world today because
what's going on in the world today
is that the air is healthy healthier
than it was 50 years ago or even 100
years ago or even 200 years ago when
they were burning coal in every house
you know they had they had the black
death in london occurred before 1900
when they finally realized they had to
stop using coal as their main fuel
and
all kinds of changes have happened which
make the air in the world cleaner today
the forest area of the of the world is
growing today as i mentioned china and
india are largely responsible but europe
as well and we're not losing forest
there's more forest in the united states
today than there was in 1900 by a small
margin but there is more
and that's because people are planting
trees because you see the more wood we
use people think oh the more wood we use
the fewer trees there will be no the
more wood we use the more trees there
will be
because when people use wood someone has
to plant another tree
in order to produce the wood for the
next person that wants it so building
all our house structures out of wood
actually is one of the main reasons why
we have so many trees here the reason
haiti has almost no forest is because
they build their houses out of
substandard concrete which falls on
their heads in an earthquake and killed
250 000 of them
after the japanese tsunami which killed
no one in the earthquake unfortunately
20 000 people died in the tsunami but
that wasn't because buildings failed
that was because of the wave the
buildings in japan are built to
standards that can withstand an
earthquake of nine
in haiti an earthquake 20 times less
less powerful killed a quarter of a
million people it's powerful right now
because
they built their houses out of wood that
is treated for termites it was easy
treatment for termite resistance in wood
if they would build their houses with
termite resistant wood they would have
forests all across the country like
their neighbor dominican republic has
it's a famous border between the two
from the satellite you can see haiti
completely deforested and the dominican
republic green and luscious can be i've
been there it's a beautiful place i'm
not going to haiti so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]